chi mi ha preceduto molti i relatori che
mi hanno preceduto sono uomini del
futuro
io mi sono sempre definito un uomo del
presente proprio perché io credo che
tutto il mio lavoro non non riesca a
fare degli enormi passi in avanti per
ciascuno è chi è si deve accettare
io molto spesso faccio dei passi
laterali cioè cerco di vedere cerca di
vedere le cose
vediamo tutti il quotidiano quindi cui
si parla semplicemente con un punto di
vista assolutamente personale mi occupo
di di spazio
mi sono andati in architettura e faccio
design perché poi è stato un po il
destino di di tutti quelli della mia
generazione quindi quando guardo questo
tavolo semplicemente faccio mi sposto
lateralmente diventa sta roba qua è una
specie di di atto di magia nel senso
titolo che vi ho proposto era la forma
come contenuto no allora io mi immagino
sempre un cilindro per cilindro del
prestigiatore il contenuto del cilindro
e un coniglio bianco quindi la forma
contenuto come contenuta in questo senso
c'è sempre una seconda lettura un
secondo messaggio questo è un ottavo che
rinuncia alle quattro gambe portanti per
lo meno non è che rinuncia scommette
esagera quattro sono portanti 171
restanti sono morbide quindi anche una
specie di gioco di prestigio perché la
la linea esterna perimetrale e tutte
morbida quindi la gente mi ricordo
quando nel 2001 abbiamo presentato se
nella immobile le toccava e pensavo che
stavo semplicemente galleggiasse perché
erano tante le gambe anche se erano
morbide ma poi io in fondo progetto
questi tavoli semplicemente perché poi
sono teatri di storie che possono
accadere questo era lo schizzo con cui
ho presentato il progetto e cappellini
cioè per me
a me interessava quello che succede
sotto al tavolo quindi ogni ogni cosa e
vettore non una forma come contenuto poi
voglio dire noi abbiamo giocato tanto
con
con intanto con l'idea della piazza noli
della piazza è la più grande idea
architettonica italiana
questo luogo un incontro voglio dire
forse il maggior prodotto d'esportazione
architettonica italiano per me si riduce
in scala 1 a 250 ed entra nei salotti
delle persone perché un po ci siamo
dimenticati il senso della piazza ma è
semplicemente anche questo è un gioco di
magia un semplice piroetta un movimento
laterale che serve a riportare al centro
dell'attenzione un tema come quello
della piazza
oppure vado in piazza gino valle a
milano dove gli edifici sono fatti così
sono disegnati da gino valle stesso a
cui è dedicata alla piazza e per fare un
un edificio per come sede del della
squadra del milan
decido che questa forma in fondo deve
essere semplicemente portatrice di un
vettore di un contenuto
quindi questi atleti corrono sul tetto
del soffitto impattano con una palla
quindi quella roba lì diventa messaggio
era man motion emotion però esattamente
trattare anche la superficie di un
edificio non mio
come una tela in fondo veramente è
sempre un passetto laterale questo è un
architettura nel nel giardino fantastico
di bomarzo che mi ha sempre colpito cioè
io guardo il mio quotidiano perché poi
ciascuno scusate se lo sceglie il
quotidiano non è che se necessariamente
da qui a casa vostra
fate sempre stessa tra rinfacciate
prestare diverse quindi questo è il mio
quotidiano in fondo io e la bormio
quotidiano faccio il passetto laterale e
diventa questa roba qui questo è un
lavoro che ho fatto per per trent
l'ultima triennale la ventunesima in
fondo non ho fatto altro che
estroflettere bomarzo la gente entrava
in questo igloo specchiato ed entrava
dentro la mia testa
infatti da quelle orecchie lì erano dei
grandi amplificatori da cui uscivano
parole estratte da un libro che ho
scritto io e si intitola il design
spiegato a mia madre quindi praticamente
un ossimoro perché vi assicuro che non
si può spiegare il design a vostra madre
assolutamente non si può
possa la madre quando ho provato a
spiegargli qualcosa mia madre purtroppo
è morta ma quando provavo a spiegarle
qualcosa lei sorrideva e diceva fabio
cosa vuoi mangiare che vi è
semplicemente si trova qui no allora io
provo a spiegarlo attraverso le orecchie
del della mia testa la gente entra
dentro
racconta un po di storia insieme a un
testo di otto e mezzo di fellini
io sono molto attratto dai visi dei
volti delle maschere in fondo sono sono
il nostro vero biglietto da visita no
noi ci esprimiamo con tantissima mimica
facciale
questa è la maschera tipica del teatro
greco questa maschera serviva a celare i
volti reali degli attori quindi comunque
a dargli delle connotazioni artificiali
ma se vi aveva anche un altro uso
assolutamente interessante serviva per
amplificare la voce
adesso c'è questo microfono che
volgarmente viene detto gelato anche se
non si lecca
ma pensate nel teatro greco erano enormi
gli spazi aperti quindi c'era bisogno di
questi aggeggi che amplificano i quasi
magicamente la voce anche lì la magia vi
interessa moltissimo insomma questa
questa maschera diventa una maschera un
po fuori scala per il nostro quotidiano
e qui sto viene un'altra cosa anche lì
il mio quotidiano sono state delle
letture di oscar wilde e mi batte in
questa frase che mi colpì moltissimo
tutti gli uomini mentono ma dategli una
maschera e diranno la verità allora nemo
serve per dire la verità e questi occhi
a me sanno di verità io sono molto
affascinato da datevi bovi come artista
abbiamo veramente perso una persona ci
ha dato tantissimo quindi quando ma
chiesto un cliente di fare uno show room
di rivestimenti in mosaico a berlino ho
pensato alla sua trilogia di berlino li
ha fatto tre album i due anni 77 78 tre
album e pc allora messo i suoi grandi
occhi di due colori diversi in vetrina
di uno showroom di mosaici quindi voi
dite sempre questo spostamento laterale
cioè la trasfigurazione della realtà
guardare la realtà con occhi diversi
semplicemente occhi diversi in questo
caso con gli occhi degli hnwi allora per
me questa è un'immagine che ho preso da
interessa mattina mi serviva alcune
immagini due pilastri questi sono
esattamente 2 pilastro cui sono
imbattuto quando mi sono trovato a fare
questo locale qui che solo cara milano
fatto un bel po di anni fa quindici
venti anni fa avevo questi due pilastri
ma semplicemente questi pilastri per me
sorreggevano il palazzo che c'era sopra
questo locale
allora diventavano queste bracciano di
questo dio li anche stavo leggendo
il testo sacro dei morti egizio c'era
questo dio e sino alla sugar reggeva la
volta celeste e allora questi due
pilastri hanno immediatamente diventati
le braccia del dio show e sorreggevano
la volta di questo locale a milano
oppure voglio dire ci si imbatte il mio
quotidiano e anche visitare mostre a
mare artistico io amo tantissimo de
chirico allora le sue piazze d'italia ne
ha fatte
centinaia di cassino no sono ossessioni
gli arti sono ossessionati sono dei
maniaci ossessivi evidentemente a me
diventa questa roba qui la diretta
relazione io guardo de chirico mi sposta
lateralmente socchiudo un po gli occhi
perché poi è sempre questa capacità di
trasfigurazione ragazzi la progettazione
e trasfigurazione e diventa questa roba
qua oppure guardo tiziano vuol dire
questo del 1538 era bellissimo ora
pensate a tiziano pensato a tutti gli
artisti alla sua epoca prendevano queste
donne quasi sempre per la maggioranza
prostitute dalla strada che facevano
stendere su un triclinio le dipingevano
le trasformavano in the perché poi tutti
questi quadri stimavano venere alle
acque
la dea seduta quindi la divinizzazione
della prostituta era il top
questo è totale potere di
trasfigurazione esattamente quello che
accade con l'arte no io ho cercato di
farlo con questo divano interrato qui mi
interessava è fatto anche di superare la
soglia del dell'opera artistica quindi a
valicare la barriera per me quello è
fondamentale cioè non pensare che
l'opera d'arte sia altro da sé quanto in
qualche maniera interagire e farla
propria attraversare la soglia forse
quello è l'unico passo in avanti mi
piace invece che laterale cioè varcare
la soglia dell'opera andiamo avanti
questo
questa l io parlo sempre punto di vista
uomo italiano eterosessuale quindi il
femminino è sempre negli occhi e
comunque nei desideri di un uomo per me
è diventato questa è la mia prima
architettura pensata c'è stato il primo
primo lavoro in cui queste gambe di
donna che sono sempre una specie di gol
per qualsiasi l'uomo diventano la soglia
di un negozio di moda oppure
il quotidiano può essere anche uno
stilista come tommy hilfiger questa una
pubblicità delle sue che aveva chiesto
di fare una vetrina speciale per questo
lancio a milano eccetera eccetera
insomma ne approfitti anche
eventualmente per fare un passetto di
critica dc tommy hilfiger mio caro su in
fondo non fai altro che proporre
lifestyle sarà gente non sono altro che
dei kit di montaggio di un immaginario
come questo quindi qualsiasi passo
laterale lo decidi tu qualsiasi punto di
vista ha deciso come progettista e ne
fai quello che vuoi
io per esempio quando vedo questa
macchina qui che la gente fa impazzire
io non sono per niente appassiona di
macchine non possiede una macchina per
me quando mi chiedono di fare un quelle
una mustang però mi piace il nome
mustang massa è un cavallo selvaggio
allora quando mi chiedono di fare lo
stesso oggetto per per un prodotto di
robin e gli houthi giocattolini in legno
per bambini la mustang diventa un
cavallo vero no tra l'altro pensate a
questo piccola divagazione
e incredibile che ancora noi giudichiamo
il potere di un motore in horsepower
cioè noi ancora siamo così legati ad una
vecchia logica di trasporto con
l'animale equino da trasformare ogni
potere qualsiasi autoveicolo persino di
una ferrari 500 cavalli dal cofano a
prisco 500 cavalli quindi per me io
quando vedo quella macchina lì per me è
questa roba qua trasfigurazione pure
oppure quando vedo questo voglio dire
nella nostra città si è abituati a
questo tipo di di panorama per me questo
panorama qua diventa quest'altra cosa
questo è successo qualche anno fa
sindaco di milano mi chiese di risolvere
il problema che c'era montenapoleone
mancanza di verde e parcheggio selvaggio
semplice mixi le due cose ti sposti
lateralmente le auto diventano il vaso
perfetto replicata in vetroresina tra
l'altro te le fai pagare da fiat perché
doveva fare il lancio della 500 cabrio
quindi proprio il cerchio si chiude
sempre lo devi chiudere come progettista
perché in fondo la che doveva portare a
casa il risultato
guarda io non so se avete sentito e
letto il discorso di ringraziamento di
bob dylan al premio nobel quindicenne
non è che che fa le cose perché pensa
vincerebbe
premio nobel per la letteratura 16 un po
paragonato shakespeare e dice secondo
voi si preoccupava di quanto sarebbe
piaciuto ai critici o di quanto sarebbe
arrivato ai posteri quella si
preoccupava di sul palco c'entra
l'attrice che deve recitare il ruolo
il teschio per amleto vero finto chi lo
fa e macchia 3d se ci fosse stata cioè i
problemi sono più contingenti quindi
questo far quadrare i conti
questa è la vera quotidianità questo è
il vero mestiere del progettista il suo
spostarsi di lato e scelsi punto di
vista
andiamo avanti oppure questo io io
guardo questo tra l'altro accade spesso
nelle strade dissestate della nostra
italiano e per me diventa questa roba
qui da un altro in un'occasione la
storia raccontare perché questo è un
progetto io o intere o intitolato green
line in onore ad una mia visita a beirut
dove un certo punto fate conto che in
questa città
pazzesca si era spezzata in due perché
da una parte c'erano i cattolici e
dall'altra ciani musulmani però si
sparava da una parte all'altra barricata
fai conto voi siete cattolici macy e
musulmani
questa strada in mezzo non ci passava
più nessuno e nel manto d'asfalto
iniziavano a crescere le piante quindi
questa questa xvi a questa strada fu
ribattezzata green line la linea verde
un po magari aver dei boeri che sogna
per milano però bellissimo che un fiore
che la sua forza attraverso lo strato
d'asfalto e riacquisti dignità e propri
anche ad insegnare agli esseri umani
la spesso assoluta insensatezza oppure
guardo ai vicoli di napoli e mi viene di
dire io vivo a milano dove ci sono le
strade più più eleganti e quelle le
strade del quadrilatero della moda
allora appena ne ho l'occasione
napoletani giu
milano questa e via della spiga nello
specifico questo è un intervento fatto
per le luminarie di qualche anno fa
l'assessore chiama serie progettisti e
mi assegnò via della spiga e io decisi
di replicare spaccanapoli in via della
spiga con degli elementi completamente
fatti di diodi luminosi oppure decido di
prendere l'oggetto feticcio della mia
gioventù del designer di affrontarlo con
prendi e prendendo in prestito un
personaggio dal simposio platone si può
sempre la tona e un libro in cui
ciascuna da un'interpretazione
dell'amore c'è questo drammaturgo che è
un certo punto racconta questa storia è
l'essere umano è un essere perfetto
felicissimo asessuato e così felice che
dà fastidio agli david e si lamentano
con zeus e per farvela breve zeus gli fa
venire tutti in fila questi caspita di
esseri umani e con delle salette li
divide a metà costringendoli a ritrovare
quindi la perfezione originaria
semplicemente per ritrovando la
complementarietà del mascolino del
femminino quindi io che ho sempre
considerato perfetta la panton chair
faccio zeus e la spezza in due la spesso
in in under e questo è un altro
spostamento laterale un altro punto di
vista la perfezione in fondo non esiste
la ricerchiamo sempre inseguendo c sulla
superficie del pianeta no siamo sempre
un po abbiamo vedeva che si cercano
oppure guardiamo quest'altro cioè
ciascuno di noi passa attraverso fasi di
assestamento stadi evolutivi diciamo
questo tra l'altro in divano che mi
ricorda moltissimi anni a new york
io ho sempre detto quando vi a new york
e i barboni i clochard chiamateli come
volete gli homeless sono i veri padroni
delle città perché questi si appropriano
di qualsiasi cosa che per strada noi in
fondo non consideriamo lo spazio
pubblico con uno spazio nostro spazio
pubblico e dove casomai lanciamo la
carta per terra non c'è non ce ne
curiamo mentre loro sono i veri padroni
la città in fondo dovremo imparare molto
da loro
quando ho proposto questo piano ha
cappellini ho detto giulio questa roba
qui è adaptation esattamente
l'adattamento alla versità delle
condizioni di trovare comodità in
qualsiasi punto di rottura
ed è quello che ci consente di andare
avanti no oppure questo è un altro
divano che ho disegnato sempre per
cappellini
pensate che io è un pò adaptation che
questa cosa qui io l'ho disegnato solo
questo elemento qui che non sta in piedi
e questa è una cosa che mi interessa
spiegarvi è come un io e come un io io
non sta in piedi
dico sempre che anche linguisticamente
non l'io è contenuto nel noi
se poi specchiate noi è all'ennesima no
io all'ennesima potenza quindi noi ha
senso soltanto se tanti io si mettono
assieme
quindi questo divano non è altro che
tanti moduli messi assieme che si
possono unire all'infinito e creare un
divano per noi no per far sedere
chiunque dall'altro viene usato adesso
molto nelle hall degli aeroporti si
chiama and en della congiunzione io e te
e te tra l'altro end al contrario è
anche dna in una specie di catena di
genoma diverso per la generazione più
condivisi va se volete oppure la tua
quotidianità è neanche fatta di
riferimenti classici essere se non dire
corbusier il il famoso lettino della
psicanalisi sigmund freud e queste sono
le macchie di rorschach i test di
rorschach e ti fanno vedere questi test
e tu devi dare delle interpretazioni di
queste macchie per me diventa non è
stata qui quindi mi auto analizzo tratto
interessante ragazzi che fate conto che
nei primi del novecento fine ottocento e
primi novecento freud era il fighissimo
del suo periodo storico quindi quella
roba lì che le corbier il giovane le
corbusier disegnare il 28 non è altro
che figlia esattamente di quel lettino
quindi è interessante come il design un
po risenta evidentemente degli influssi
culturali delle mode diciamo perché
freud era il re a quel tempo la
psicanalisi veramente la disciplina
regina c'è molto di più le stampanti 3d
era era la nanotecnologia del momento la
psicanalisi
insomma questa roba qui diventa lapsus
quindi prendo il
il divano di freud lo fondò con la shell
ondine rabbiosi e cambio tutte le i
pattern persiani del tappeto di freud
con le macchie di rorschach oppure
prendo la bandiera americana
semplicemente solo non trasfigurando
semplicemente un po socchiudendo gli
occhi diventa questa roba qui che uno
showroom che ho fatto nel in tempi non
sospetti di bushismo adesso sarebbe
quasi a replicare per tramp ma insomma
sedicente this assemblando la bandiera o
rimanendo nel tema delle bandiere come
milano qualche anno fa mi chiese di fare
un padiglione per shanghai che
rappresentasse la città allora ci si
interroga su quello che la la croce
rossa in campo bianco ti accorgi che la
croce rossa era la nobiltà di capobianco
era il popolo e case della nobiltà di
una città oggi novità e nobiltà creativa
allora ci metti boccioni ci metti taglio
di fontana attenti e bocciano il fontana
non erano milanesi quindi che cos'è
anche lì la forma come contenuto e
diritto di terra e non di sangue tu sai
affermando con una giunta di destra che
comunque il simbolo della città e la
croce rossa in campo bianco
reinterpretata con l'eccellenza di
milano che non sono milanesi un po in
barba alla lega qui c'è tra l'altro a
miuccia prada qua c'è l'ultima cena di
leonardo che non era milanese malfa
milano e qui anche lì questo è da
manuale degli architetti e l'unica cosa
storici da trovare su internet perché
ora è ma merci 7 è praticamente in
disuso in materia preistorica
sta di fatto che è un po l'approccio ai
ripianino però questo mi fa venire in
mente quando arriva questo cliente
americano vice fabio rifanno negozi di
scarpe e gli faccio sta roba qui perché
in fondo è semplicemente rapportarsi a
una mensola nello spazio la fa impazzire
socchiude gli occhi e diventa questo
questo reticolo un po favolistico un po
immaginario un po magico perché avrò
magia me piace tantissimo
guardate io non credevo tanto e la magia
un amico qualche anno fa mi ha omaggiato
di un biglietto per vedere david
copperfield
secondo me mi ero dimenticato perché poi
l'età adulta ti fa dimenticare una serie
di cose no allora è andato lì dice no
stop o per fini sociali la tana cetera o
ma ha messo in prima fila al suo amico
abbastanza fortunato questo alla vostra
distanza david copperfield mi ha fatto
cadere la mascella cioè e na roba
lasciarsi travolgere la magia è
bellissimo ed è così infantile come
approcciano è così il sempre l'occhio
del bambino ecco perché vi ho detto per
me nel cilindro c'è sempre il coniglio
bianco
andiamo avanti guardi un gesto così e
diventa questa cosa qui questo anche lì
è questo questi sono anni di
sperimentazione come sempre con questo
progetto dimostra che sia una bisaccia
questo era uno stand fieristico ragazzi
uno stand fieristico per un produttore
mosaici quindi ciascuno può stracciare
interpretazione ciascuno può far
diventare quotidiano straordinario
qualsiasi cosa
questa è la maniglia meno comprato in
casa quando il fatto casa mi ha detto
che lo voglio semplicissima il tondino
italo eccetera
però poi a vendola sempre sotto gli
occhi ho detto ragazzi ma continuità non
mi accontenta quindi o semplicemente
asportato materia e questa materia ha
originato un cuore questo perché piccola
microstoria all'interno per me era il
progetto più difficile disegna la
maniglia perché odio le porte mi fanno
proprio schifo le porte le divisioni né
barriere non riesco a sopportarle quindi
disegnare la maniglia era quasi una
contraddizione in termini evidentemente
e qui il titolo di questa maniglia come
molte volte per qualsiasi opera spiega
tanto le intenzioni love open store
soltanto l'amore apre le porte quindi
non basta impugnare un tondino ma devi
togliere materia al tondino disegnare un
cuore e impugnare un cuore è qui queste
sono le copertine di due monografie
fatte negli anni passati però anche
queste trasfigurazione pura qui a quel
tempo mi piaceva a mettere la mia
immagine in copertina poi semplicemente
ho detto che senso ha
io mi vedo così io mi vedo che lo chiudo
gli occhi faccio un passo laterale mi
apro il petto trovo un fiore dentro di
me e lo dono all'interlocutore
e questo è forse l'interpretazione cui
mi riconosco di più guardate
per chiudere io non sono certo che
l'evoluzione sia un passo in avanti ma
sono certo che l'evoluzione sia un passo
di danza
quindi godetevela ciao
[Applauso]